FREEDOM AND WE WISH HIM A QUICK
RECOVERY.
>> Trace: MICHIGAN GOVERNOR
GRETCHEN WHITMER FACING LEGAL
BACKLASH OVER NEW COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
ORDERING A BAN OF INDOOR DINING
THAT TOOK EFFECT WEDNESDAY.
A TRADE GROUP IS NOW SUING TO
TRY AND STOP IT SAYING
RESTAURANTS HAVE LOST THE
ABILITY TO USE THEIR REAL AND
PERSONAL PROPERTY IN ANY
MEANINGFUL ECONOMICALLY
BENEFICIAL MANNER.
PLAINTIFFS HAVE NO ADEQUATE
REMEDY FOR THIS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE MICHIGAN
RESTAURANT AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION JOINS US NOW.
JUSTIN WINSLOW.
IN THE SUIT WHAT ARE YOU HOPING
FOR?
YOU WANT 50% CAPACITY BACK IN
THE RESTAURANTS, 25%, WHAT
WOULD YOU SETTLE FOR?
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE WOULD LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET BACK TO DOING WHAT WE
KNOW HOW TO DO.
SAFELY SERVE GUESTS AND KEEP
OUR EMPLOYEES SAFE AT THE SAME
TIME.
THE DATA IN MICHIGAN SUGGESTS
AS MUCH.
WE HOPE IT WILL ALLOW
RESTAURANTS TO GET BACK TO
DOING WHAT THEY DO BEST.
>> Trace: A QUICK SOUND BITE
FROM THE GOVERNOR AND GET YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> THE SITUATION HAS NEVER BEEN
MORE DIRE.
WE ARE AT THE PRECIPICE AND WE
NEED TO TAKE SOME ACTION.
>> Trace: JUSTIN, SHE IS RIGHT.
THE SITUATION CLEARLY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IS GETTING WORSE
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I FIND
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS IS
RESTAURANTS ARE ALWAYS THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT, RIGHT?
RESTAURANTS AND BARS AND GYMS.
LOW HANGING FRUIT AND THEY ARE
THE FIRST ONES SHUT DOWN.
I PULLED UP THIS STUDY.
THIS IS FROM PUBLIC HEALTH
ENGLAND.
THE BRITISH EQUIVALENT OF THE
CDC.
THEY SAY THE NUMBER ONE PLACE
IN THEIR CONTACT TRACING THAT
PEOPLE REPORT GOING IS THE
SUPERMARKET AND ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO 16, 1% OF PEOPLE
REPORTED BEFORE THEY GOT THE
VIRUS GOING TO A RESTAURANT OR
CAFE AND YET NOBODY IS TALKING
ABOUT SHUTTING SUPERMARKETS AND
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT SHUTTING
DOWN THE RESTAURANTS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> LISTEN, I THINK YOU’RE RIGHT.
THE NUMBERS DON’T LOOK GREAT IN
MICHIGAN NOW AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS HAVE INCREASED
AS WELL.
THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY HAS
BECOME A CONVENIENT SCAPEGOAT.
WE HAVE TRIED VERY HARD TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW MUCH WE PUT
SAFETY AT THE FOREFRONT OF
EVERYTHING WE DO EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
IT SHOWS UP IN THOSE NUMBERS
EXACTLY AS YOU REFERENCED.
THE NUMBERS IN MICHIGAN.
THE CONTACT TRACING DATA OCCURS
IS PRESENTED AND SHOWS MINIMAL
TRANSMISSION FROM THIS INDUSTRY.
IN FACT MUCH LOWER THAN MANY
INDUSTRIES THAT REMAIN OPEN FOR
BUSINESS RIGHT NOW.
WE CAN’T HELP WONDER WHY WE’RE
SINGLED OUT AGAIN AFTER BEING
SHUT DOWN 85 DAYS EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
>> Trace: THE "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" RAN A STORY SAYING
THEY PULLED UP THE NUMBERS
SHOWING MORE THAN 50% -- UP TO
75% OF THE INFECTIONS WE JUST
DON’T KNOW WHERE PEOPLE ARE
GETTING INFECTED.
TO POINT AT DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES AND SCHOOLS AND SO
FORTH IS DISINGENUOUS.
THE TRUTH IS SCIENCE MATTERS
AND WE REALLY DON’T KNOW.
I WANT YOU -- THIS IS PART OF
THE LAWSUIT QUOTING ON THE
LAYOFFS.
YOU SAY MORE THAN 40% OF
RESTAURANTS ARE NOW LIKELY TO
CLOSE.
AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
THESE ARE NUMBERS FROM THE
MICHIGAN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES.
AT LEAST TEMPORARILY.
250,000 EMPLOYEES ARE LIKELY TO
BE LAID OFF FROM RESTAURANTS
OVER THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
BIG FINANCIAL HIT TO YOUR
INDUSTRY AS WE MOVE TOWARD THE
HOLIDAYS.
>> YEAH, EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE DON’T TALK ABOUT THIS THE
HUMAN TOLL.
250,000 PEOPLE LAID OFF OVER
THE HOLIDAYS AND WE DO NOT HAVE
THE SAFETY NET THAT WAS IN
PLACE EARLIER IN THE SPRING
WHEN THERE WERE CARES ACT
DOLLARS TO SOFTEN THE BLOW.
THE BLOW WILL BE TREMENDOUS.
6,000 MORE RESTAURANTS WILL
CLOSE IN THE COMING MONTHS
BECAUSE OF THIS CLOSURE AND
250,000 MAYBE 300,000 EMPLOYEES
WILL LOSE THEIR JOBS AND I
DON’T KNOW IF THEY HAVE ANY OF
THE BENEFITS TO HELP SEE THEM
THROUGH THIS.
>> Trace: I’VE BEEN READING
ARTICLES ON RESTAURANTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND REBUST PLANS,
TO GO MEALS THEY’RE SERVING AND
GIVING THE FOOD TO MAKE THESE
MEALS.
HAVE YOU FOUND ANYTHING THAT
CAN AT LEAST, YOU KNOW, TRY AND
TIDE SOME OF THESE BUSINESSES
OVER UNTIL MAYBE YOU GET 25,
50% CAPACITY BACK?
WHAT’S THE THOUGHT THERE?
>> THIS IS -- THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY IS RESILIENT AND
CREATIVE AND FOUND A LOT OF
WAYS TO HELP ITSELF SURVIVE.
A LOT OF RESTAURANTS LEARNED
FROM THE SPRING WHAT WORKED AND
WHAT DIDN’T WORK.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR THAT 40%
NUMBER THAT MEANS 40% OF
RESTAURANTS KNOW THAT CARRY-OUT
OR DELIVERY WON’T GET IT DONE
FOR THEM AND THEY CAN’T AFFORD
TO LOSE MORE MONEY OVER THE
COMING WEEKS AND MONTHS SO
THEY’LL JUST STAY CLOSED.
>> Trace: PEOPLE DON’T REALIZE
IN CALIFORNIA IT’S EASY TO HAVE
OUTSIDE  DINING FOR MUCH OF THE
YEAR.
MICHIGAN NOT SO EASY AND
DEVASTATING FOR PEOPLE IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
WINTER WILL BE TOUGH IN
MICHIGAN.
>> Trace: GREAT OF YOU TO COME